y volvemos a economía en directo américa
ya está listo nuevamente en el estudio
consultado jorge por supuesto vamos a
iniciar dándole seguimiento a todo lo
que ocurre en europa del este- y cómo se
encuentra la economía de ucrania con
escala todas estas tensiones bueno este
conflicto que data de 2014 ha metido
mucha presión a la economía de ucrania y
la afectación va desde el empleo la
inversión e inclusive la vida cotidiana
con la amenaza de invasión en las
últimas semanas e incluso antes de la
misma el gobierno ucraniano ha dicho que
esta presión sobre la economía es una
guerra híbrida en ucrania los
restaurantes no se atreven a tener
comida más que para un par de días y el
transporte marítimo del mar negro los
mercantes deben sortear con cuidado los
buques militares rusos los puertos del
mar negro operan con normalidad por
ahora pero en poco tiempo el peligro es
que las aseguradoras podrían cancelar su
cobertura para el transporte marítimo
algo que ya sucedió raúl por ejemplo con
los vuelos comerciales
ucrania es uno de los principales
exportadores de grano del mundo hay
cientos de buques contenedores mueven el
12 por ciento del suministro global de
trigo y el 16 por ciento del suministro
de maíz la moneda nacional el grip no se
ha devaluado de forma constante y el
martes se desplomó un 1 por ciento luego
de que rusia reconoció a las dos
regiones separatistas las cuentas
bancarias del país también se han
retirado unos 12.500 millones de dólares
hasta finales de enero decenas de
parlamentarios empresarios y altos
ejecutivos han salido de quiebra en las
últimas semanas el centro de
investigaciones económicas y
empresariales aseguró que el conflicto
con rusia le ha costado a ucrania una
pérdida de 280 mil millones de dólares
en su producto interno bruto entre 2014
y 2020 y esa cifra raúl se podría
aumentar inclusive este año bueno pues
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa fue la que
no se aumente tanto cambiamos ahora de
tema porque las autoridades chinas
reabrieron una investigación en contra
del imperio de jackman el fundador de
alibaba bueno y no solamente contra este
famoso multimillonario sino contra tres
grandes empresas de tecnología en china
en los últimos días la empresa alibaba
holding pensó en holdings inc mictlán
han perdido alrededor de 100 millones de
dólares por el temor de una injerencia
estatal según bloomberg por ejemplo esta
ofensiva regulatoria pidió a mei wang
que redujera la tarifa que cobran los
restaurante en las regiones afectadas
por la pandemia fuentes dijeron a
reuters que el gobierno chino pidió a
los bancos estatales y a las empresas no
bancarias verificar algunos datos de
andy andy es una filial de alibaba group
la empresa de jackman ha sido de las más
afectadas por la campaña del gobierno en
contra de lo que ellos llaman capital
desordenado a finales de 2020 hay que
recordar el gobierno chino canceló una
oferta pública inicial de 37 mil
millones de dólares de este grupo que
habría sido de ejecutarse la mayor
oferta inicial pública del mundo las
acciones de alí babá cayeron hasta un
5,3 por ciento en la bolsa el grupo
global de servicios financieros mcguire
emitió un informe sobre esta situación
en la que lo tituló represión máxima
bueno jorge de noticias de nuestra
región argentina va a recibir un nuevo
préstamo así es y esto se da en un
contexto de cuando el país el gobierno
alberto fernández renegocia una
multimillonaria deuda el fondo monetario
internacional el banco mundial aseguró
que le prestará otro 2 mil millones
adicionales el director de operaciones
del banco mundial al ex mantra sandburg
confirmó durante una reunión con el
ministro de economía argentino martín
guzmán guzmán perdón que el organismo
multilateral avanza en la aprobación de
la cartera que superarán los 2 mil
millones de dólares en fondos para este
año en 2020 argentina recibió el apoyo
del organismo para financiar proyectos
en las áreas de respuesta a la pandemia
así como la expansión de servicios
públicos básicos para los sectores
vulnerables argentina llegó a un
principio de acuerdo con el fbi para
refinanciar esta deuda de 40 mil
millones de dólares esa economía
enfrenta una inflación que supera el 50
por ciento y es una de las más altas del
mundo por e indicadores como están
empezamos con las acciones chinas ahí
cerraron al alza con los valores de la
tecnología y las nuevas empresas
energéticas liderando las ganancias
mientras que en europa las acciones
subieron por los buenos resultados
empresariales entre ellas las del
fabricante de automóviles estudiantes
desde rusia operó con ganancias tras las
limitadas sanciones de occidente y
europa y vamos ahora con la cifra del
día jorge la cifra es 6,4 por ciento se
fue el crecimiento del producto interno
bruto de hong kong en 2021 este rebote
se da luego de una contracción en 2020
del 6,1 por ciento en economía se conoce
como rebote a que este efecto post
pandemia cuando las economías que más se
contrajeron en 2020 fueron las que más
han mostrado crecimiento en 2021 jorge y
re votamos hasta parís ahí está ya
nuestra periodista natalia ruiz con toda
la información de la actualidad francesa
[Música]